[Musica]
buonasera e ansia mi sembra di parlare
ai grammy con i tavolini super chic
intorno a me dunque partiamo facciamo
come se fossimo tra amici per anche per
come dire esorcizzare questa borsa c'è
ancora la luce vi vedo tutti posso
guardarvi negli occhi
bene io ieri siamo venuti qua a fare le
prove avevo costruito tutto un discorso
per fare un po il figo anche per fare
bella figura su un parallelismo tra
masaccio e lucio fontana vi ho portato
due delle loro opere
poi siamo andati a cena c'è stata la
partita dell'italia non sono molto
appassionato di calcio ma ho vissuto
molte vibrazioni grazie alla come dire
al calore pugliese e
parlando con gli altri speaker anche
questo il bello di ted non mi piaceva
più mio discorso cioè non ero più
convinto io ho detto domani che faccio
io questo non l'ho scritto per per così
per fare la la performance e proprio
accaduto così alle 4 43 ero ancora
sveglio perché io veramente non ero
convinto da da questa performance
questa è la bellissima vista grazie tra
l'altro al ted per l'accoglienza alla
vista della mia camera si provi la
plauso di nuovo la vista del lungo mare
di barletta di ho detto qua si fa giorno
devo quagliare aprì la cartella di
barletta seleziona tutto cancella quindi
tutto questo pippone per dirvi che ho
cambiato strategia ho scelto di
improvvisare mero fatto il testo
precisino e tu no l'ho l'ho cancellato
questo era il parallelismo che voleva
fare secondo me era un po troppo
sofisticato cioè non perché vi sto
trattando da scemi e era troppo
sofisticato per il contesto dinamico di
questo di questo evento volevo creare
giustificare questo parallelismo tra un
pittore del rinascimento fiorentino
masaccio e un avanguardista del
ventesimo secolo lucio fontana cercando
avrei voluto farlo cercando di spiegarvi
come due artisti che apparentemente non
hanno nulla in comune
in realtà a distanza di secoli possono
dirci la stessa cosa ovviamente ognuno
con il linguaggio della propria epoca e
questo discorso era masaccio ci porta in
un altrove pittorico sfondando la parete
della basilica di santa maria novella
con la prospettiva che i rem oggi gli
permette di creare una realtà virtuale e
allo stesso tempo nel novecento fontana
ci porta oltre la superficie pittorica
in questo caso squarciando letteralmente
la superficie delle sue opere
questo e sarebbe stato tutto questo
timore per 10 minuti però poi dato che
io ho sempre detto da grande voglio fare
piero angela perché credevo che fosse un
mestiere di io me lo immaginavo come una
professione di colui che va in vacanza e
racconta le proprie vacanze alle persone
che lo guardano da casa
però secondo me è la chiave della
divulgazione non è il voler fare bella
figura io ieri avevo scritto un discorso
per fare bella figura di fronte a voi
questa sera per quello diceva un po
troppo sofisticato secondo me il
divulgatore dovrebbe come dire fare un
passo indietro rispetto ai contenuti di
cui parla
altrimenti poi diventa un personaggio
che crea una sorta di interferenza
rispetto alla potenza del messaggio che
cerca di trasmettere cioè non è ancora
iniziato il pezzo forse è ora di di di
tacere quindi il senso la home la
metafora di questa sera dato che ogni
speech di di ted a una metafora è io
vorrei dimostrare questa sera che la
storia dell'arte e l'arte in generale
non è quella disciplina polverosa e un
po accademica anche un po stantia che si
studia al liceo come una successione di
termini tecnici di stili di etichette ma
in realtà è dovremmo quasi parlare di
storie dell'arte al plurale e
un'antologia un insieme di racconti che
gli artisti hanno cercato di raccontarci
di storie che gli artisti hanno cercato
di raccontarci nel linguaggio nel caso
della pittura ad esempio della pittura
con i dettagli che cosa sono i dettagli
sono storie scritte nel linguaggio della
pittura allora nella notte tra ieri e
oggi scelto 5 superstar della storia
dell'arte per dimostrarvi per fare
questo questo esempio di fronte a me
questo è un caso classico di come per
secoli gli artisti ci hanno trasformato
in realtà in in detective no lo
spettatore diventa un detective che deve
andare a cercare gli indizi
nell'immagine di fronte a sé per capire
cosa sta accadendo apparentemente ci
sono questi due un po arrogantelli due
si chiamano gli ambasciatori in realtà
chi di voi ha già visto questo quadro
rapido sondaggio nessuno sia ok quindi
mi fa piacere non siete super
appassionati della apparentemente qui
tutto
tutto va bene non ci sono questi fieri
di sé anche un po tronfi vestiti con
questo abito di seta rosa molto un po da
fashion week diciamo ma il pittore per
quello dicevo si trasformò in detective
dissemina una serie di indizi per farci
capire che ci sono molte cose che non
vanno
in quell'anno 1533 la prima cosa intanto
è ad esempio il mappamondo che è
ribaltato non è nell'ordine giusto
in realtà poi scopriremo questo ritratto
è una sorta di trattato di geopolitica
dell'anno 1533 mappamondo risaltato c'è
un liuto tra i due uomini
l'uomo di destra e john denti ville
dell'ambasciatore di francesco prima di
francia a londra si annoiava tantissimo
londra era sempre felice quando l'altro
giordo e serve un prelato andavo a
trovarlo talmente felice che in
quell'anno chiese a hans holbein di
ritrarlo con con il suo amico però il
clima politico del tempo era totalmente
discorde c'era martin lutero la riforma
protestante l'esercito ottomano che era
le porte dell'europa europa che si
sentiva minacciata c'era enrico viii che
voleva lo scisma anglicano staccarsi da
da roma e hans holbein cerca di tradurre
quel clima di angoscia attraverso i suoi
dettagli lo strumento musicale ad
esempio a una corda spezzata si leverà
corda spezzata un po si è quel tratto
bianco che vedete questa onda rispetto
alle altre corde dritte poi c'è un libro
di aritmetica che è aperto alla pagina
della dvd
ovviamente la divisione matematica ma
anche divisione come discordia che
regnava nell'europa del tempo però c'è
anche una cosa molto più inquietante che
è questo questa macchia bianca che
sembra una macchia bianca ma osservando
il quadro di lato discorso si scopre che
quella macchia bianca in primo piano in
realtà un teschio bisogna a londra la
national gallery di londra
non so se avete fatto questo gioco e
dovette mettere perché non certo ne
scusa
dovete mettervi discorso e vedere il
teschio nella giusta prospettiva
cosa vuol dire il clima politico è
discorde voi le vostre ricchezze sono in
realtà fugaci perché tanto morirete
anche voi nonostante i vostri soldi e
gli oggetti e gli abiti con cui di cui
vi siete circondati però c'è una
soluzione è ovviamente anso al benda la
soluzione da credente quale era e ha
nascosto un crocifisso là in alto a
destra dietro la tenda di broccato come
dire che per dare una chiave per uscire
da questa apparenza terrena e questo
discordia come dire politica storica
politica anche il bronzino veramente sto
soffocando io anche il bronzino ma è
uscito il bronzino
no qui questa è una sorta di quadro
pornografico per per l'anno 1545 cioè
uno dei rari baci con la lingua vedete
la lingua dei personaggi che che si
toccano il bronzino come holbein
utilizza i dettagli nascosti per in
questo caso non parlarci di come dio sia
la soluzione per uscire dai problemi
della politica e della vita quotidiana
ma per per per darci una lezione
sull'amore a volte si dice anche modo un
po retorico l'arte da lezioni di vita
però sono un po parole vuote in questo
caso ci insegna bronzino che la
sofferenza è parte integrante dell'amore
e come lo fa anche qui nascondendo un
dettaglio molto significativo questi due
si baciano pure un bacio alla francese
con il tutto sorridente che lancia
petali di rosa verso la coppia di
innamorati però se abusiamo la vista
notiamo che dietro questa gioia
apparente il tutto il piede destro del
tutto è trafitto da spine proprio per
dire che non è tutto rose e fiori nelle
coppie voi secondo me quelli che sono
venuti accompagnati lo sanno e quasi fa
una campagna di sensibilizzazione sulle
malattie sessualmente trasmissibili
perché schiacciato nel bordo sinistro
pinto mette una figura tormentata che
secondo i trattati medici del tempo a
tutti i sintomi della sifilide cioè mal
di testa non ha i denti perdita di
capelli pelle di colore olivastro sarà
il caso di accelerare questa natura
morta con formaggi mandorle e pretzel
che è uno dei tipici quadri di fronte al
quale nessuno si fermerebbe al museo
perché spesso tra l'altro le nature
morte sono accostate nelle sale fatte
apposta per le nature morte dove c'è
sesso prima del bagno prima dell'uscita
abbiamo i piedi gonfi nessuno si ferma
di fronte a queste opere invece sono
varchi temporali verso un'altra epoca
questa opera è stata dipinta da una
donna tra l'altro clara peters che si
firma sul coltello
in primo piano la scelta dell'oggetto
non è casuale perché il coltello era un
accessorio molto caro alla all'epoca
cioè per dire quando si era invitati a
cena si portava da casa il proprio
coltello come oggi andremo con non so le
scarpe o la borsetta quindi sceglie
l'oggetto più prezioso per dire sono io
cara peters ad aver dipinto questa tela
ma va oltre che la rapidità del se era
una sorta di femminista ante litteram
ovviamente in un mondo in un'epoca in
cui il mondo dell'arte era ancora una
roccaforte maschile e per dire sono io
donna clara peters ad aver dipinto la
tela nasconde il suo volto lo faceva
spesso lo nasconde nella nel riflesso
della giara del coperchio della giara in
sembro commosso ma invece scusate ma
dove siamo intimi
nella giara in bellarmino ovviamente ci
sarebbero tuttora ogni essendo una volta
non un istantanea ma una composizione
artificiale ogni oggetto che è presente
nella tela ha un significato preciso ma
dato che ci sono molti altri speaker non
vi dico gli altri significati degli
altri oggetti e passò velocemente alla
penultima opera che è la ronda dei
carcerati di van gogh sempre per dirvi
come vale la pena a rallentare il passo
di fronte alle opere d'arte per
ascoltare ciò che gli artisti hanno
voluto dirci nascondendo i dettagli nei
loro dipinti non visitare i musei come
se avesse come se avessi una lista della
spesa in testa devo vedere questo questo
questo il resto non ci presta molta
attenzione qui ad esempio tutti gli
storici dell'arte si concentrano sul
volto dell'uomo in primo piano che
dicono dato che van gogh ha dipinto
questa ronda dei carcerati quando era
nello spedale psichiatrico questo luogo
come dicono quelli con poca fantasia è
un luogo dell'anima cioè incarna lo
stato d'animo che l'artista aveva allora
in questo senso di claustrofobia e di
prigionia all'interno dei propri
pensieri negativi però c'è un punto di
speranza anche qui che si perde lo
spettatore distratto due farfalle che
volteggiano leggere sopra la ronda di di
prigionieri e qui la voce tremolante
aiuta perché sembra coinvolto dalla
sofferenza del dell'artista nostra
scherzando
ultimo quadro mi hanno detto che se
avevo due minuti bonus pero di non di
non aver come dire che non sia l'ultimo
ted cui partecipa alla mia vita a causa
del ritardo allegoria della pittura
questo rapidissimo è una sorta di
biglietto da visita di vermeer
c'è questo viaggiatore francese che
vuole andare in olanda vedere il pittore
di cui parlano tutti arriva da vermell
non trova neanche una sua opera e
vermeer dice forse il caso che io
ottenga qualcosa che dimostri quello che
sono capace di fare quindi crea una
sorta appunto di portfolio di ciò che è
capace di fare questo a suo atelier
immaginario perché in lui dipinge ma in
realtà in un sottotetto in legno che non
aveva nulla a che vedere con questo
ambiente lussuoso questa sciarpa tra
l'altro è la sciarpa della ragazza con
l'orecchino di perla questo non è dato
da raccontare alle grigliate questa
estate però ci cerca di sottolineare il
carattere artificiale dell'immagine per
dire attenzione questa finzione
ad esempio il piede sinistro del del
cavalletto su cui appoggiata la tela non
c'è per dire può stare in piedi lo
stesso tanto è uno spazio reale non è
che devo che è sottoposto alle leggi
fisiche normali e proprio perché uno
spazio finto ci mette anche una tenda in
primo piano che un po un sipario al
teatro e si parli dice guardate che da
qui in poi non è più una realtà concluso
dicendo che l'arte anche quella dei
secoli passati
resta sempre attuale se si riesce a
guardare con uno sguardo innovativo
perché quello che si dice per me era in
realtà lo diceva anche questo giovane
artista belga nel 1929 il famoso rovani
madrid quando dice se sin evaso in pip
che ci sentiamo un po presi per il culo
se non è una pippa questa cos'è ma
magari ti dice come x men
non fatevi ingannare dalle immagini
perché questa è una pippa dipinta
nessuno potrebbe riempirla di tabacco e
fumarla quindi è soltanto un'immagine
messaggio attuale non ho una fine però
il principio il messaggio che la storia
dell'arte e interessante credo sia
passato
[Applauso]